WE NEED TO GO TO NANCY PELOSI
WHO IS SPEAKING RIGHT NOW.
>> THE IRANIAN ATTACK ON AN
AMERICAN ASSET THAT HAS ENDOWED
US TO WHO MOTIVATED IT, WAS IT
OFFICIALLY SANCTIONED OR A ROGUE
ATTACK, WHATEVER IT IS, IT WAS
IRANIAN.
HOWEVER WE GO FORWARD FROM HERE
HAS TO BE STRATEGIC AND SMART
AND CLOSE IN ALLIANCE WITH OUR
ALLIES.
WE HAVE COMMON INTERESTS IN THE
REGION.
WE KNOW THAT THE HIGH TENSION
WIRES ARE UP THERE.
WE MUST DO EVERYTHING WE CANNOT
TO ESCALATE THIS SITUATION BUT
ALSO TO MAKE SURE THAT OUR
PERSONNEL IN THE REGION ARE
SAFE.
>> AND YOU'RE PUSHING FOR -- IF
WE WERE TO LAUNCH MILITARY
ACTION --
>> ONE THING THAT I CAN SAY -- I
WAS JUST TALKING GENERALLY.
IN TERMS OF -- IT WAS A MEETING
IN TERMS OF WHAT WE WERE TOLD.
BUT ON EVERY OCCASION THAT WE'RE
ENGAGED WITH THE ADMINISTRATION
IN TERMS OF OUR NATIONAL
SECURITY, WE MAKE IT VERY CLEAR
THAT IN ORDER TO GET ENGAGED IN
ANY MILITARY ACTIVE
ANY MILITARY ACTIITY
ANY MILITARY ACTIIIE
ANY MILITARY ACTIACE
ANY MILITARY ACTIACTIVITIES, WEH
ANY MILITARY ACTIACTIVITIES, WEV
ANY MILITARY ACTIACTIVITIES, WEE
TO HAVE A AUTHORIZATION OF
MILITARY FORCE, A UMF THAT IS
CLEAR IN OUR CAUCUS AND EVEN
AMONG SOME REPUBLICANS.
I DON'T SPEAK FOR THEM.
BUT ALSO WITH OUR DEMOCRATIC
COLLEAGUES.
>> ARE YOU PERSONALLY CONVINCED
BASED ON THE INTELLIGENCE YOU'VE
SEEN THAT THIS WAS AN IRANIAN
ATTACK IN INTERNATIONAL
>> YES.
>> [QUESTION INAUDIBLE]
>> THEY SAID THEY WILL DO THAT.
THE BRIEFING THAT WE HAD THIS
MORNING IS -- FOR THE TIME THAT
I WAS THERE, THEY HAD INCREASED
THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE THAT WERE
IN THE MEETING TO BE BRIEFED.
AND THEREFORE, THEY DECREASED
THE LEVEL OF INFORMATION THAT
THEY GAVE US.
AT ONE POINT THAT I CLEARED THE
ROOM.
BY THEN, I HAD -- WE HAD OUR GUN
SAFETY EVENT THAT I HAD TO BE
AT.
SO I DON'T KNOW WHAT THEY GAVE
AFTER I LEFT.
IT WAS WELL-INTO THE BRIEFING.
SO WHAT WILL THEY GIVE TO A
BROADER -- I DON'T KNOW HOW MUCH
MORE THAN IS IN THE PUBLIC
DOMAIN, BUT NONETHELESS, WE WANT
TO BE CURRENT AND WE WANT THE
CONFIRMATION OF IT.
THAT IS OUR MEMBERS OF CONGRESS
HAVE TO MAKE A DECISION AND
FULLY BRIEFED ON WHAT THE
PROSPECTS ARE AND WHAT THE
POSSIBILITIES ARE AND WHAT THE
CHOICES ARE.
>> DO YOU AND THE ADMINISTRATION
AGREE ON IRAN?
>> THEY DIDN'T SAY YES OR NO.
JUST MADE OUR STATEMENT.
>> SO YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT THE
ESCALATION.
ARE YOU ADVOCATING ANY
PARTICULAR ACTIONS?
>> NO.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT THE ARRAY OF
OPTIONS ARE FROM THE DEPARTMENT
OF DEFENSE.
THE PRESIDENT KNOWS.
HE DID NOT SHARE THAT WITH US.
>> THANK YOU.
>> [QUESTION INAUDIBLE]
>> I HOPE THAT'S RIGHT.
WE TRIED TO -- LOOK, THREE
THINGS TO REMEMBER.
WE MUST -- THIS IS A DANGEROUS
SITUATION.
WE'RE DEALING WITH A COUNTRY
THAT IS A BAD ACTOR IN THE
REGION.
WE HAVE NO ILLUSIONS ABOUT IRAN
IN TERMS OF THEIR BALLISTIC
MISSILE TRANSFERS, ABOUT WHO
THEY SUPPORT IN THE REGION AND
THE REST.
SO WE HAVE AN UNTRUSTWORTHY
ADVERSARY.
THE HIGH TENSION WIRES ARE UP IN
THE REGION FOR A LOT OF
DIFFERENT REASONS.
SOME BILATERAL, SOME RELIGIOUS,
WHATEVER.
THE HIGH TENSION WIRES ARE UP.
THIRD, WE MUST ACT IN A WAY THAT
DOES DEESCALATE AND DOES NOT
ESCALATE THE TENSIONS AND THE
SITUATION THERE.
AGAIN, I COME BACK TO WHERE WE
BEGIN.
WE MUST BE FULLY ENGAGED WITH
OUR ALLIES AS WE GO FORWARD.
I'M HOPEFUL THAT YOU'RE RIGHT
ABOUT WHAT SENATOR McCONNELL
SAID ABOUT WHAT THE PRESIDENT'S
RESPONSE MIGHT BE, BUT I HAVE NO
IDEA.
THEY MAY HAVE HAD THEIR OWN
CONSERVATION.
MEASURED BY WHAT MEASURE, WE'LL
SEE.
>> YOU THINK THE WHITE HOUSE
WILL CONSULT WITH CONGRESS
BEFORE TAKING ANY ACTION?
>> I CANNOT REALLY PREDICT WHAT
ACTIONS THE WHITE HOUSE WILL
TAKE.
THEY DID CONSULT WITH US TODAY
OR INFORM US OF -- WE HAD AN
OPPORTUNITY TO SHARE OUR
THOUGHTS WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION.
PRESIDENT SAID WE'LL HAVE MORE